him the power of the powerful I did
hundreds of different mushy designs
there was almost four or six months of
me just doing Design After design
Disney's known for having Easter eggs a
lot of their animated stuff do you know
Beast is in Aladdin no no
so I take them all the way down the hill
all the way into the thicket oh it's so
awesome
you did VeggieTales Veggie Tales
you're doing a whole thing on veggies
yeah
thanks to Betsy for sponsoring this
video stick around so you can find out
how to get 15 off of your next bestie
purchase hey everybody welcome back to
another episode of animators react with
a very very special guest for you today
Tom Bancroft Tom has done pretty much
all your favorite animated films yeah so
I worked on eating the Beast Aladdin
Lion King Pocahontas a little bit of
Brother Bear and of course Mulan I
created Mushu the dragon wow we've got a
list of bangers man yeah thanks for
animating my whole childhood
so I did I do Comic Cons and things like
that of course and I get people coming
out tonight
I was like one of hundreds
it's gonna be really interesting talking
to somebody who really has the hands-on
experience here learning about the
techniques I went into making this the
imagination what the profession actually
entails I can't wait to get into it me
too
go
so you started with a Roger Rabbit short
film was that your first thing so first
thing for Disney was Roger Rabbit it was
roller coaster rabbit
you'll never lose it and it was a short
film that went out with a film that
nobody remembers I hope they remember
roller coaster rabbit but they don't
remember Dick Tracy probably it was
award Beatty and Madonna movie that came
out back before you were born probably
did that like hit you in your foot in
the door and then you stuck with it well
yeah so I'd gotten hired I went backing
up I have a twin brother I always bring
this up when I talk about my past
because we did everything together and
so we went to Cal Arts before that
California's to the Arts and got some
animation training couldn't afford to go
more than a year and a half and we just
gambled everything on get our portfolio
into Disney and they took us they were
just about to gear up for this new
studio they're about to build in Florida
the Walt Disney Florida Studio that was
going to be in Disney MGM Studios and it
was a working tour you could walk
through and watch us animating on things
and so at age 21 we're working for the
best studio in the world yeah I find out
I'm going to be the assistant animator
for one of the top 10 animators at
Disney Marquette and I became Mark Ken's
assistant and hadn't learned how to do
the job yet
they literally they were training us on
the job and so they said well it's a
show there's a tour going through we've
got to have you doing something so that
you work on this animated short so we
took a long time on roller coaster
rabbit because we're using it as
training too
[Music]
and now I'm like literally within the
first couple weeks Markham animates a
scene and he just plops all the drawings
down and I have to now go put a piece of
paper over that and clean up his
drawings so I'm taking a legendary
Disney animator stuff and I'm just out
of school and I'm trying to redraw it
and I'm just uh it was it was a little
crazy
[Music]
so I did Young Simba in Lion King and so
yeah none of this is mine this is Mark
hen I did that one yeah where he's just
trying to catch up it was one of my
first Simba scenes actually it's funny
because until we just saw that I had no
idea I worked on the beginning of like I
thought my stuff is much further but
this was one of those shots that was
just thrown to me if I remember right so
I think I did this now I'm starting to
freak out but maybe I didn't so when you
say you did that one what does that mean
like you started the initial drawings
like yeah so somebody else did the other
two lines and then I was given December
so like in a lot of computer animation
at Pixar and stuff like that one
animator will do all the characters in
The Shot no matter who's in it right but
most 2D animation Productions in these
days we were cast to a character and so
I only did Young Simba but we would
split it up that way so that we really
got to know that character and not just
the drawing side of it which was
important but it's for acting reasons
too we needed to get to know the
personality of that character and if
you're jumping from character to
character you're gonna make them all
move like young Simba because that's
maybe the one you know the best but now
I'm animating Mufasa I'll make him move
like young Simba because I don't have
any practice on him and I don't know his
personality
that's my shot everybody look left
how many frames would you get through in
a day of work I don't count to me you
can't do crazy work like this where
you're basically working a fraction of a
second every moment of your life right
I'm literally everything on my desk is
fractions of a second because every shot
is different like some of them are short
shots but they're very complex and hard
and has lots of characters and so if I
was animating this shot is a very
difficult shot thankfully I did not do
it
and none of those drawings are alike
right everything is moving and so none
of these shots no matter how fast are
really like an easy shot
[Music]
yeah by the way in Disney we always said
there's no such thing as an easy shot
just less hard
do you have a specific shot from Lion
King that you remember being the most
difficult shot you had to do I'll tell
you one it's not the most difficult but
but because it was my first ones it made
me stop and wait almost a week before I
animated oh wow
so literally the shot where he jumps and
he starts there he is rolling down the
hill so I take him all the way down the
hill all the way into the thicket you
know after that he has to crawl through
the thicket oh it's so awesome trying to
figure out what would he look like for
every single animal right and I didn't
know how what quadruped Anatomy was
either well as you can see it's such a
fast shot in the pacing right how fast
he's going I think it's a little
scramble in there yeah and so and I want
it to be like magic right yeah I'm young
and trying to think how would the
Masters do this right and you can't by
the way do reference for this I can't
take a little lion cub and throw it down
the hill and film it so I just literally
really put it away and for three four
days I just crammed animal anatomy books
and videos of lions and stuff I really
should have already done I was like oh I
have to like really so in a way it's
some of my earliest stuff but crazy to
say I'm kind of still proud of it
because I'm like well it looks great it
looks awesome it looks great what a lion
would look like as he was tumbling down
a hill yeah it doesn't look like your
first time drawing Simba yeah it just
looks like Simba yeah well fortunately
the cleanup people they refine it even
more my drawings probably look pretty
stinky and then they would clean it up
and kind of improve it so that's why
it's a group effort bye order of the
emperor one man from every family must
serve in the Imperial Army so Milan is
the movie I'm most excited to talk about
today and you did all of the Mushu
animation right no no okay so yeah when
I first started there was a chance I
would have it would be me and maybe a
couple animators helping me because
Mushu at the time when I first came on
was going to be a smaller character then
they got Eddie Murphy that blew him up I
am the powerful the pleasurable the
Indus
it has the film kind of evolved they
started giving Mulan lines to to Mushu
because he was the biggest named star
but he was also funny and it was working
even in just the storyboard phase hello
hello
I did hundreds of different machine
designs at the beginning there was
almost four or six months of me just
doing Design After design of different
Chinese dragons and then I started doing
animation tests with different voices
and things like that for another six
months so it was almost a Year's worth
of just developing Mushu before I did my
first production animation shot I ended
up getting about 10 people I think that
animated Mushu and so it ended up being
that it was me designing the character
and supervising animation and doing
probably the majority of the animation
at least proportionately to each
animator so yeah it became a huge job
there were many nights I stayed up all
night yeah I miss you let's say it paid
off it did I don't know we should do it
that way all the time that's such an
amazing character and I you definitely
feel Eddie Murphy like coming through in
the just the facial motion and just even
the body language of Mushu it's so cool
yeah
I can see you look he looks so pretty
this is a minor thing but one of those
things you don't think about the
reflection of him in the actual hat I
actually had to animate him on a curved
surface copying the drawing and then as
he puts it away he gets a little smaller
like there's like subtle little
perspective changes happening and things
like that it's just one of those nutty
things that you don't expect is going to
hit your animation desk the unfortunate
thing is I only did it once so just it
worked and they're like yep it looks
like he's in there
I would say that Mushu is Eddie Murphy
and me if we had a baby dragon
all right because there is so much of me
in him and there is a lot of Eddie
Murphy too but I feel like I see more me
than I see Eddie it's just Eddie's voice
coming out do you feel like with all of
your characters you put like a little
bit of yourself or maybe a lot of
yourself into them I think every
animator does it's hard not to do that
you know Disney's known for having
Easter eggs and a lot of their animated
stuff can you tell us a little bit about
that like is it is this everybody like
just hallucinating are you guys actually
like sitting there like I had to draw a
thousand of these images I'm bored let
me just mess with this one so it's a
little bit of both but more of the
latter okay so we're making these films
one frame at a time and that's a very
monotonous kind of a thing right where
you're just kind of like ah what can I
do to make this a little bit more fun
and so sometimes we do add some things
all of them are innocent the ones that
everybody kind of hangs on to are the
ones where it's like dirty right yeah
most all of those are false and we can
talk about that another time and dig
deep into that but there's a lot of
really fun innocent ones do you know
Beast is in Aladdin no no
what like bees from Beauty and the Beast
the Beauty and the Beast
hang on to your turban kid
[Music]
this is him stacking up all these toys
and by the way look that's somebody's
dog right there the background painter
put his dog in there that has that red
scarf around it as we pan up he also
added the Beast there on the right as a
toy right and so that's a film that had
just come out Pixar does this all the
time because they got it from us we
originated this okay just started the
inside Easter eggs by the way nobody has
permission like that's the clear thing
we need to make here because it wasn't
like Disney corporate knew this was
happening
secret frame they would hear about it
later usually the directors didn't even
know we were just sticking them in there
going yeah nobody will notice because we
didn't have freeze framing back then now
we have the technology where every
single frame can be found scrutinized
back when I saw Star Wars as a kid oh
I'm not gonna see Star Wars ever again
right it's weird to think of a narrow
not too long ago when like you'd watch a
movie in the theater and like that was
the only time you could ever watch it
once it's gone later it was gone yeah
and Nico I'm older than I look
that felt
for me okay get this all the citizens of
the kitchen come together fruits
vegetables small kitchen appliances you
did VeggieTales VeggieTales
we're not talking about VeggieTales yet
VeggieTales is like the most Charming
way better than it has any right to be
CG animation from the very early days of
CG animation yeah it is it predates Toy
Story a lot of people don't know that
but this was way way before its time
they were putting out the longest form
animation that anybody had ever done
when they put out that first VeggieTales
VHS it was groundbreaking CG animation
was brand new and just sort of
discovering how to create even just very
simple shapes like a cucumber and a
tomato and it turns out doing these very
simple vegetables was like the smartest
thing they could do you must go to him
you must go to the king what the very
first thing that they put me on was to
animate Esther you can see she's almost
like a little bit of Disney
World yep she's got this nice strand of
hair yeah I was like God that little
strand that's what we would do
so they trained me in like three weeks
Maya and now fortunately you don't have
arms and legs and we had just worked out
how do they hold things right and so
they just they literally would just make
it kind of nearby their body and as long
as it's moving with the body it feels
like he's holding it and then he can
even gesture simple gestures with it and
you kind of just believe it right nobody
question it there's a really tricky shot
I did where she has to she kind of takes
her crown off and holds it and looks at
it and kind of thinks about the weights
of being a queen
like literally this is what's supposed
to be happening
we had to kind of like go well wait at
what point does it look like this is
floating down but we didn't have one kid
complain yeah they all kind of got it
they'd seen the Disney movies that we
were basically parking back to let's
just look at how much that thing is
floating around the subtle implication
that she has like telekinetic Powers
Yeah but I had never heard anybody think
or say that it honestly it didn't even
register when I watched the first time I
just I saw her picking it off her head
looking at it didn't occur to me that
she didn't touch it there's that line of
this disbelief that we just kind of go
with because we've seen so many other
sort of films in the past it's kind of
magic so you were saying you left the
studio and then went back to Disney so I
got laid off and it went bankrupt and
they had to lay off everybody but a
skeleton crew but I was one of them so I
went back to Disney and worked on
brother bear so I helped out on rutton
took I'm trying to find where the lights
keep getting all worked up about it gee
I don't know maybe the goods pooped onto
me rotten to feel like the most Canadian
characters in this as well yeah and uh
let's hear what you think about that rut
specifically like I was watching some
Brother Bear Clips last night I loved
this movie growing up it was one of my
favorite movies I love it and again
going back to kind of Mushu and Eddie
Murphy Rick Moran has played right right
yeah Rick Moran is at such a specific
face and you know his features and the
scrunching eyebrows and you feel that so
much in the character like I want it
it's awesome it's a whole other video
but I really want to dig down on the
crazy technique that we did for rotten
took let's dig down it right now because
it's early CG animation and 2D animation
put together and nobody knows it really
oh I see it do you see it the antlers
it's the antlers you'll see every shot
they've made it harder on themselves
there let's get the antlers to like
connect now they can't get them apart
you cannot figure out those antlers
there's no way in perspective especially
so what we would do is we would hand
draw rough out the animation and we
wouldn't even put the antlers on at all
we just do the heads and the bodies
animating all that so we would then scan
those drawings once that was in the
computer they literally created in Maya
a model CG model of the heads of right
and to just the head with the full
antlers we now line up the Maya rig
frame by frame pose to pose but now it's
fully animated right like it would add
all the in-betweens that's what Maya
does so we could now put our rough
animation over that animation of just
the rig of of the of the head and
antlers line them up and now Trace off
frame by frame oh wow every single
antler so it's locked in because it
really was the only way it was going to
feel locked and if you watch this it's
locked they're not sliding around
anywhere and even nowadays with
technology as it is they would be
sliding it's all done but there's a
little slide I take it back
that's also that's a great way to
integrate the tech back then it seems
like you know it was it's going like
okay we have this entirely proven
workflow for hand drawing stuff we have
a very complicated geometric form that
needs to maintain that structure as it's
moving which is very hard to draw but
had I not come
from
and I pulled up my sleeves I'm like I've
just done CG animation on vegetables so
let me show you how it's done yeah no
but anyway s it's like you were
animating every shot two three times so
it did make them the hardest characters
in this movie and most people don't know
it they're such awesome characters
though so you mentioned you have your
own studio now what do you guys
primarily do so yeah it's called
pencilish Animation Studios we're crowd
invested so I created a company where I
said what if people that are either fans
of mine or just love animation and
things like that could actually invest
in a startup company and own a piece of
an animation company we're creating
original Concepts so Bjorn The Last
Unicorn is one it's about a unicorn that
wants to come out of hiding after
thousands of years he's The Last Unicorn
Juju brain is another one about a
preteen girl and it's done in a more TV
animation Style by the way and then
Bjorn Last Unicorn is done fully
animated but it does look hand drawn on
the campus and stuff is that all yeah
what I call digital animation digital
animation patent pending it has such a
like awesome look to it because of that
thank you looks really cool you can
watch these full episodes on pencilish
your YouTube channel yeah they're shorts
but yeah we have full episodes there
we're coming out here and just sharing
all these stories with us it's like the
one thing we can do in return is check
how you work I always say this like when
it comes to the internet if you see
something that you like the biggest
compliment you can give the person that
created that thing is to just go look at
more of their stuff that's like the
deepest compliment you can give an
artist
in my humble opinion that's great I
agree agreed don't give me money look at
my stuff yeah yeah so please go to the
pencil Studios YouTube And subscribe I'd
really appreciate it hey guys Jordan
here I'm super excited today because
today's sponsor Bessie has a brand new
shoe it's called the storm burst and
it's their dedicated hiking boot so the
storm burst model has rubber soles that
add extra grip and slippery wet
conditions and there's an extra layer
for warmth and cold it's kind of funny
that it's called that because La just
went through some crazy story we got an
insane amount of rain so like normal
Bessie shoes these hiking boots are also
waterproof as well so it doesn't really
matter if it's been raining for a month
straight so all of veshi shoes are 100
waterproof thank goodness also if you
love animals they're 100 vegan all of
their shoes even the new hiking boot
model and I mean almost everyone here at
or digital loves me outside whether
we're hiking whether we're rock climbing
whether we're one Wheeling we're all
getting active somehow so you know that
the whole crew is rocking their vessies
lately but also they're made from this
dimatex material so we like to go on
Hikes here in California well now we can
go during the summer or the winter
because this dymatex material it keeps
our feet cool in the summer but also
warm in the winter so if you want to go
check out the new storm burst model or
just go buy one of the other models that
they have on the website head to
bessie.com quarter crew use promo code
cornered crew so you can get 15 off of
your next pair of bessies that's
bessie.com quarter crew and use the
promo code Corridor crew for 15 off I'm
gonna go for a hike now and remember say
yesi to Bessie I had a blast with these
guys would not mind doing this again so
if you have anything that you want to
see us talk about uh put it in the
comments you know something we can
either put down or compliment or some
secret that we want to tell maybe right
but you're natural at this that was like
the smoothest like so good for common
stuff any guesses done on the show well
I do a podcast
wait what's the name of your podcast the
Bancroft Brothers animation podcast Link
in the description below Tom thanks so
much for all these incredible stories
and to be able to sit down with somebody
who Hands-On did the work has the
stories I'm always fortunate to be able
to sit here on the couch and like get
the first hand knowledge it's like you
know this is a big class that we just
taught but I happen to be the one actual
student sitting right here be like oh
the whole time and I get to raise my
hand and nobody else except for Fenner
he's the only other one like I raise my
hand and there's no one else behind me
that gets called on instead
that's real life for you that's right
now right now thanks for watching
Everybody we'll see you in the next one
[Music]
oh you want to see me show off
no red stop
you really want to do this before the
video is over
please don't die
it's too soft and nose dived
all right ready I'm gonna just give this
a shot then uh where's my one oh yeah
okay wait let me solve the audio problem
behind every strong man is a worried
father
I'm gonna make sure that his audio
sounds good
and the camera is exposed correctly so
that he can show off to all of his
friends